authorities in Texas are now arresting
migrants who illegally swim across the
Rio Grand into eag passs Governor Greg
Abbott signed a law allowing police to
arrest and charge people suspected of
entering the country illegally
additional razor wire has also been put
at Eagle Pass Crossing in defiance of
the Biden Administration who issued a
cease and deist order this as Biden
cabinet members will be hosting their
Mexican counterparts in Washington today
to address the Border as Democratic
Mayors speak out over how the crisis is
plaguing their cities watch we are also
a city right now that is facing a
humanitarian crisis and a fiscal crisis
unlike anything we've seen in the last
25 years and that as a result of what we
know is the ongoing influx of Migrant
arrivals who are seeking Asylum so what
is Congress going to do meanwhile
lawmakers on Capitol Hill fight over the
lack of a full-term spinning Bill
keeping the proper resources from
reaching our border Texas Congressman
chip Roy with some strong words on the
house floor yesterday watch we are
sitting here doing the same thing again
it is Groundhog Day in the house chamber
all the time every day yet again
spending money we don't have so today's
meeting in DC is supposed to begin at
noon today um obviously this is
something that we got to deal with uh
Texas law finally into effect and it
doesn't look like the governor is going
to change course on this guys yeah
you've been down there a lot you've
heard these stories and yesterday we had
a chance to hear some of these stories
because uh two moms were in front of
Congress they were upset that mayorcas
didn't show up for the hearing but they
talked about their stories one mom said
that her daughter had and it's not this
is this is uh Josephine but another mom
Tammy Noble said her daughter was uh in
her own bedroom and was uh raped and
then strangled with a cord by an MS13
gang member who is here illegally and
said she had just turned 20 years old
old a few days ago and she said I got
the news that no mother ever wants to
hear that your daughter is dead and this
woman Josephine Dunn her daughter died
from fenel which we know coming across
the southern border
listen in my humble opinion Mr mayor's
border
policies is partially responsible for my
daughter's
death his wide open border policy allows
massive quantities of poisonous fenal
into our country my family is
broken my heart is broken and he
couldn't even be here to face me
today whatever he's doing that is more
important than facing me
today I don't know what that could be
you're hearing stories and it's not
we're looking back and saying Matt there
was a tragedy then it's not like we're
looking back at a past War this is
ongoing uh I'm sure you guys saw the
story ice came out and gave a report
that they had to let a known rapist go
in Boston in the Boston area despite our
filing an immigration detainer the
individuals released back into the
community by the criminal court so our
our courts are letting us down our
policy to diminish and uh emasculate ice
is letting us down and it's leaving
people Democrats and Republicans
vulnerable on the streets which just
make other people like uh I bring up
that uh charlem man the god who came out
and said Everywhere I Go
people are talking about the border and
illegal immigration it hits everybody it
does indeed uh the apparently the re the
Republicans who run the the house and
run that committee had invited Mr
mayorcas to uh speak yesterday and he
said I can't do it uh yesterday but I
can do it any other day and they said no
you got to be there obviously he wanted
they wanted him to be there in the room
to hear the testimony from uh the two
moms uh and they said nope uh you're not
going to appear in person just send us a
written statement what's interesting
about the dynamic now is you know the
Republicans did not have the votes to
pass this last year now things are
really stirred up there's a possibility
they still don't but they're closer to
being able to uh impeach him the problem
with a lot of moderate Republicans is
the standard for impeachment is high
crimes and misdemeanors what is the high
crime he committed other than simply
following a policy that's not a crime
the policy was established by Joe Biden
and his administration I think the one
thing people would point to is you got a
guy who's lied on Border Patrol agents
accused him of whipping when he knew
knew it wasn't true because there's
leaked memos that show that the
secretary knew that that was not true
Joe Biden said the same thing he just
literally lied on on my state and the
military uh Texas Military as well as
Texas DPS there's now correspondence
showing that he knows that it wasn't
true that Texas uh did not allow those
uh migrants to drown in the water with
the mother the two kids the Mexican uh
authorities could have saved them and he
won't even face the parents that have
lost children because of his policy so I
I just think he's just he should be
impeached for not doing his job it is a
crime to come into our country illegally
and when you allow that to happen as an
Administration then you are involved in
that crime too in the betting I'm Steve
duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart
and click here to subscribe subribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis